hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation light up your Western blots
florescent Western blotting tips tricks
and more presented by dr. Paul Haney
senior product manager protein and cell
analysis Thermo Fisher Scientific and
savvy grenman of labrys and I will be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lavaridge and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
visit wwm Oh Fisher calm before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
question into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. Paul
Heaney I will now turn the presentation
over to him
greetings everyone today and I would
like to speak with you about Western
blotting specifically around tips tricks
and ways of making fluorescent blotting
as easy and productive as possible
though I wanted to start about some
facts about Western blotting Western
body remains one of the most widely
performed protein detection applications
and it's estimated that well over 5
million Western blots are performed
globally each year Western body remains
quite popular despite being a fairly old
technique developed in the 1970s and
it's particularly useful because it can
termined protein expression up and down
regulation response to drug treatments
or stimuli in very complex samples it's
commonly used downstream of protein
purification drug treatment gene
knockout gene silencing and it provides
size information that's very important
in determining the protein species that
you're looking at here at thermo
scientific one of the focuses we have is
improving Western blotting to provide
you with all the products that you need
for reliable experiments beginning to
end all the way from protein gels to
transfer methods to imaging systems
substrates antibodies markers and more
we work to make this a workflow where
each step leads the next and hopefully
provide you the highest quality reagents
and methods available
but I want to start talking about
prescient Western blotting versus chem
II limit Western blotting
chemiluminescent Western body's the most
common method used today it's been
around for many many years and it has
many good features but for us and
blotting what your body is becoming more
and more popular due to some added
benefits it can provide
the differences between the two
chemiluminescence uses a indirect signal
generated from ends of an enzymatic
reaction to produce light usually with
HRP or elf boss where for us of Western
bodies using a directly conjugated floor
for this has some different effects on
the Western blot where signal duration
because it's using a enzyme and chemical
method the duration is limited to a few
minutes to a few hours depending on the
substrate you use where a fluorescent
Western blot is quite stable and the
light input is output is consistent over
a period of time
sensitivity wise chemiluminescence
because it uses enzymatic reaction and
there's a wide variety of substrates
available can be very very sensitive and
allow you to see down to SEM program
levels of protein fluoresce and Western
bonding can be also very sensitive
nearly as sensitive as chemiluminescence
Western blotting but you may require
higher antibody concentrations of the
secondary antibody to get a similar
level of signal consistency both systems
can be very very consistent or have
inconsistency issues depending on the
experiment being done there's possible
variation between blocks and
chemiluminescence due to substrate
changing the amount of light given out
over time and also the substrate that
people are using where fluorescent blots
tend to be more consistent lab to lab
till you lab because everybody is using
a very similar dye
um detection methods chemiluminescent
has advantage that you can acquire the
image both on film and CCD based cameras
where present imaging typically requires
light sources for activation and filters
so they're almost exclusively imaged on
CCD based or laser based imaging systems
one of the main features I'll talk about
most today is around quantitation and
one of the advantages that makes
fluorescence becoming more popular and
then for southwestern bonding you can
multiplex your sample and look at
multiple targets at the same time which
allows you to do normalization with
internal controls or look at multiple
targets at the same time and then other
considerations of chemiluminescence you
can strip Andry probe several times
which is kind of advantage by killing
the HRP signal this is a little more
difficult with fluorescent western
blotting you can't strip and probe
nearly as well but then also on
fluorescent western blotting you need to
take more care of avoiding a background
florescent contamination where
background in chemiluminescence says
it's only one light source giving off
light and no excitation energy is needed
the background can be very low
so looking once again at the differences
between a camel in essence and Western
what a flush at Western blotting here we
have two Western blots the one on the
left has three separate targets hsp90
PDI and p 23 and in this case we have
very clean antibodies and we can detect
all three of them at the same time using
a chemiluminescent signal however
because they're all producing light in
the same channel you cannot tell if the
signal is unique to each antibody even
though I can detect them separately if
doing a fluorescent Western blot such as
image on the right you can see I use two
different species of antibody primary
antibody for hsp90 and then a separate
Mouse antibody for PD I and P 23 and
then when I image them I can get two
different colors make sure the signals
coming from a different secondary and
also get the images independently where
you have the hsp90 signal on the top and
the PDI P and P 23 image on the bottom
as separate channels this allows you to
multiplex them in quality control and
also turn different channels on and off
to get the image that you want
you
now I'll start with some general tips
but for us at Western blotting for much
of the rest of the presentation and
wanted to give you some examples of why
these tips are important important as
you can see on the right there's a
variety of different artifacts that you
can get with Western blotting if you're
not careful you can get beca lean and
pixelation such as the image on the top
left you can get contamination on the
bottom such as Lintz or filters or
fibers or other material giving off
fluorescent signal and or you can have a
very high background as the image on the
top right by inappropriate blocking of
the membrane using the wrong membrane
using the wrong blockers or using the
wrong antibody concentrations
other things to avoid avoid marking
membranes with pens or pens the pen ink
in pens tends to fluoresce and will give
you signal on the membrane and Steady's
that we recommend you use pencils
handles of membranes only with powder
free gloves or with blunts forceps
powdered gloves or sharp edges will
cause artifacts on the membrane
hi everyone already I mentioned the
powder free gloves
so in the standard Western workflow
there's three basic steps
there's the separation step the transfer
step and then the probe and detect step
I'll step through each of these
individually because there's aspects of
each part that are important for
optimizing your Western blotting so for
separation our portfolio contains a
large number of products
there's the protein gels most
importantly and that's what most the
discussion will go into which gels you
use and when you use them influence your
Western blot results but then other
things that are important are you know
the gel tanks and casting apparatus that
you use for good quality gels the
protein ladders I'll speak about for
Western blotting the main thing we want
to worry about is the transfer range and
the molecular weight of the protein
you're interested in
so most typically customers will use a
BIST risk-neutral gel chemistry such as
our bolt gels and our new page gels or
at-risk glycine gel chemistry both are
very good for a broad separation range
recommended from around 10 to 250 kill
Adela's for Western blotting are often
however often people want to look at
higher or lower molecular weights and
their tendency is to stick with these
standard gel chemistry's and that can
produce some issues what we strongly
recommend is be doing high molecular
weight proteins particularly in that 200
and up range is to consider Tris acetate
gel chemistry's and if you're doing low
molecular weight proteins to say 2.5 to
40 kilo daltons We strongly recommend
Tris
try scene based gel chemistry's and I'll
show you some data on that coming up in
a few slides but first I also want to
talk about some differences between this
trick neutral gel chemistry and tris
glycine gel chemistry
so some of the benefits of a neutral gel
chemistry are related to band integrity
on Western blots one of the things that
people struggle with on Western blot or
nonspecific bands or our bands lighting
up that they don't know what they are as
you can see on the right is a both
mistress gel and a TGX gel at risk YC
and gel on the right both of the same
proteins loaded and then probed by
Western blotting and as you can see on
the right there's many breakdown
products that can occur at a high pH
triskele icing gel so if we using his
tryst of Twisp lysine if you're boiling
your samples to significantly if you're
loading buffer ph is high you can get
breakdowns of the proteins of interest
and then these will show up on the
Western blot as nonspecific bands
neutral gel chemistry is are much better
for preserving the integrity of your
protein and not causing breakdown
products the example on the right is
extreme where we use some additional
heating to show the point we're going up
and you get a breakdown products based
on the higher pH
also neutral gel chemistry's tend to be
much longer shelf-life they'll last up
to 16 months there's durable at room
temperature where triskele icing gels
have very very short shelf life only up
to a few months and performance
radically breaks down over that time and
you'll get fuzzier bands and more
protein addicts and other issues as the
gels age where results with a mistress
Dale will be more consistent over time
also typically with the mistress neutral
gel you can load higher amounts of
proteins that will allow better transfer
without disturbing band straightness
sharpness or gel smiling
going back to transfer of high molecular
proteins now talking about tryst acetate
gels these are really optimal for
separation of high microwave proteins in
the center you can sort of see a
comparison of separation gels between
Tris glycine here's a 4 to 12 of this
Tris 4 to 12 which are common gel
chemistry's and then a tryst acetate 3
to 8 percent where you can see the top
of the gels on the best Tris and
crystalizing you're really maxing out
around 200 and 250 molecular weight
we're in the same separation you can get
a 400 KD proteins separated and well
separated from other high molecular
weight proteins
also then when you look at the
separation on the western body results
the transfer results on the top right
you see EGFR here transferred doing a
fast transfer and I blot to 7-minute
transfer and the results compared to a
tryst acetate gel and a tryst glycine
mini-wedge well gel no Lex gel four to
twenty percent so even though this is a
four percent risk lysine gel which
should allow high molecular proteins to
separate you can see you get much better
transfer efficiency and brighter signal
using the Tris acetate gel compared to a
four to twenty of gradients Jill
you
it can be seen at a low molecular weight
protein here we're looking at a try
Singh Joe and with a try seen gel you
can separate proteins all the way down
to 2.5 molecular weight on the right
once again we have a 4 to 20 percent to
risk lysine gel in this case a buyer at
TGS Gel similar to the novik's gel on
the previous slide and we're looking at
caspase-3 and cleave versions of it
which are there's two different forms at
17 kilo Dalton protein and a 19 kilo
Dalton protein the trans Ising gel those
proteins are clearly separated and can
be text detected and quantified
separately
we're on a tryst Ising jelled separation
those bands is difficult and you do not
get clean resolution between them
you
however there's more to worry about than
just separation size with the gel
there's other things to worry about in
terms of how you load the sample what
markers you used and what loading
buffers you can use and some of these
things are specific to fluorescent
Western blotting that you may not have
considered
when doing chemiluminescent Western
blotting
for example sample buffers containing
blue or pink dyes such as bromophenol
blue will fluoresce and can contribute
to increased background or difficulty
optimizing exposure time as the majority
of camera systems optimize exposure for
the brightest portion of the gel which
can be the dye front so for example in
the gel in the middle you'll see a gel
image that has a bromo phenol containing
sample buffer and the 680 channel you
can see that the bro dye front lights up
very brightly but if you use a
fluorescent compatible buffer and we
make some of these available you'll see
a nice clean image on the right we're
note with no dye front issue
um you do also see some things I'll talk
about on the next slide related to the
ladder in this case this is a standard
ladder it's not fluorescently labeled in
any way intentionally yet it still
appears on the fluorescent image because
it's stained with a blue dye
talk about that here so one thing to be
aware of is always be careful to
optimize the amount of pre labeled
ladders you load onto a Western blot as
you can see here in the middle is a
standard blue dye labeled pre-labeled
ladder and when you run it on a Western
blot and in this case detect it in the
six eighty channel the blue dye becomes
fluorescent and gives you a red ladder
this is very convenient it allows you to
have a ladder that you can both
visualize visually and in a fluorescent
western blot channel but it can also be
an issue if you overload the dot the
approaching ladder which are often at
very high concentrations you can cause a
very high signal in one or more of your
prescient channels that you'll be
detecting for Western blotting other
ladders that are quite common people
will use multicolored or rainbow type
ladders that have orange blue pink bands
in it
and in that case each one of those dyes
will often fluoresce in a different
channel and you can get different
patterns in each channel depending on
the marker you use so we really strongly
recommend you use a single colored or
non stained molecular weight marker and
also make sure you dilute it down on an
appropriate level so it does not
interfere with your Western blind
other things we recommend that I'll talk
about on this slide and the next slide
is you can also use markers that have
built in Western blotting control such
in this case in the middle I'm using the
eye bright pre stain marker it's a blue
marker but also contains non labeled
bands that react in a Western blot to
act as a Western blot control so I'll
have the latter show up due to its dye
and then in a separate channel I'll have
these to control proteins show up that
let me know my Western blot worked my
secondary antibody interacts with those
bands light up and it will show me my
Western blot work and as a built-in
control if somewhat other bands are not
showing up
other than the eye right pre-stained
unlikely ladder we also offer a magic
mark this is a ladder that's composed of
molecules that react with a secondary
antibody and so they'll light up whether
you're using a chemiluminescence or
fluorescent West secondary and those
they'll light up in a variety of
different gel chemistry's it doesn't
matter if they're denatured or not be
nature so they react with the protein on
a Western body no problem and then of
course you can detect your protein of
interest and compare it to the molecular
weight directly in the Western blotting
and you can do this pleasantly your
chemiluminescent to have that ink
internal control for molecular weight
sizing that's important with Western
blotting
these are nice and that they're not
stained and do not cause impact on any
of the fluorescent channels
now I'm going to move on to the transfer
step and transfer there's a lot of
options available to researchers you can
do wet transfers such as using R&B
Trojan mini blot module you can do semi
dry transfers which is more of a rapid
transfer about ten minute transfer where
wet can be a two hour transfer or more
or dry transfers such as using in vitro
deny blot two or power blotter select
stack consumables and there's some
advantage and disadvantages across these
portfolios that I would like to talk
that have a direct impact on your
Western blot results
which one you choose depends on your lab
and what you're trying to do you know
what buffers you want how much speed
efficiency is abuse how much hands-on
time cost which membranes you want
inconvenience
some of the artifacts that people
typically see in Western blotting on the
bottom right you'll see a Western blot
done with a traditional semi dry
transfer stack that put together by hand
and then compose your own buffers and
transferred by yourself quite often you
can see artifacts such as missing bands
as you see in the second lane from the
left or other spots in the middle and
these are caused by either not having
the stack pushed together hard enough
gas bubbles that form during transfer
due to the electoral current and the
high current going on you can also see
that there's poor transfer up here of KL
h or EGFR these high molecular weight
proteins are not detected very well and
that's because semi-dry transfer the
buffers depending on which buffer you
use can often deplete and do not provide
enough time to transfer the high
molecular weight proteins on the top
right you'll see the in beiträge in
power blotter select stacks or I bought
to transfer stacks this is a dry
transfer method that I'll show in detail
on the next slide but it provides much
better transfer of high molecular weight
proteins as you can see by the Koh or
EGFR signal it also doesn't generate
gasses the consumables also have this
dry auger au s-- sheet in it that allows
very good meeting with your gel and
membranes holds the whole thing together
and you do not get dead spots you also
don't have to worry about wetting the
membranes so on even hydration which
quite often causes transfer issues
insufficient removal of methanol or
ethanol for PD PVDF which can cause
artifacts also on your gel
you
so how does a dry transfer work in this
case if you look at the image on the
right we have a depends on the device
you're using
there can be an electrode built into
consumable or not or it can use
electrodes in in the device but then
there's a top of buffer matrix which is
solidified into an auger Rose slug it
also uses a polymeric charged molecule
instead of straight buffers that move
very quickly so this slows down the
movement of the charge across the gel in
membrane so it's still very fast but
unlike a buffer which can deplete and
decafs rapidly it allows even transfer
across the whole gel and it makes a more
consistent transfer to top to bottom
because of the polymeric nature of the
electrolytes in the in the top gel and
in the bottom gel it also is a sandwich
holds together a lot better there's not
just buffers that cause gases or a
bowing that has to be pushed together
and held together by clamps the whole
system stays together as a sandwich very
well and does not introduce air gap now
there are some cons to you know the eye
block - or power block dry consumable it
does require specialized consumables and
specialized stacks and they can because
the polymeric nature of the analytes use
can cause a slight fluorescent
background compared to standard buffers
and just membrane stacks
just to kind of give some example data
so while I mentioned for us in
background it can be very very minor so
on the right I have a Western blot with
KLH go pdi-p on P 23 variety different
like your weights on the right is a
chemiluminescence detection you get very
good detection applause a wide range of
lysate concentrations so we're here
we're using a 4:3 one lysate starting at
a 20 microgram load and going down to as
little as nine nano grams of life a
floated on the right you have the same
western blot but in this case we're
detecting more proteins here we add a
killer Trojan which is a very similar
masked PDI and we detected it with a
different fluorescent antibody so a
separate channel so here you can see
we're detecting five different proteins
at the same time and can see a very
similar level of sensitivity from using
twenty micrograms down to then nine
nanograms as you can with the
chemiluminescent detection I wanted to
highlight one more aspect about
performance of what transfers because
what transfers can give very good
results and they are sort of the
standard but you have to be careful when
doing a wet block on what you choose and
particularly for fluorescent Western
blotting and that can be seen in the
membrane choice you choose so the
membrane that you choose for us at
Western body could be a major source of
background so you want to make sure you
use membranes with low autofluorescence
and this includes both nitrocellulose
and PVDF membranes
over on the right you can see a variety
of different membranes just detecting
the membranes themselves exposing them
in a prescient channel to light and do
have one second exposure here you can
see nitrocellulose it does give a little
bit higher background at 48 but it's
still pretty clean in 48 and then reduce
the background in the 680 and
800 channels
on the very bottom you have a standard
PVDF 0.45 PVDF and here you can see it
is very very high background almost
immediately washes out or blanks out
your signal in both the 48 channel and
also a significant higher background in
the 680 or 700 channel also and it would
also have high background in 556 50
channels but low fluorescence PVDF such
as in the middle you can see provides
very little or no background in the 48
680 or 800 channel so the membranes you
choose is very important and different
membrane qualities exists throughout the
world
so while optimizing membrane is
important also for chemiluminescence
it's much more important for
fluorescence detection
you
next I'm going to move on to the
immunity tension step this is both the
detect mule probing with antibodies
blockers and secondaries and then the
last step detecting on an imaging system
this is probably the most complex
portion of present Western blotting and
the part that you'll want to need to do
the most research on to find the right
antibodies and targets for you
there's a lot of parts that go into this
step there's the blocking reagents which
I'll talk a lot about there's the
antibodies and we offer a variety of
blocking regions we offer up to 70,000
different antibodies both primary and
secondary antibodies there's the washing
reagents and whether using PBS tween a
PBS TBS or tween based solutions there's
a secondary antibodies of course there's
the wide variety of alexa fluor
secondaries and alexa four plus
secondaries for us at Western blotting
as well as all the HRP conjugated
secondaries for chemiluminescent western
blotting and then the detection steps
such as imaging on a high bright FL
imaging system there's there's tricks
and important factors in each one of
these steps
I'll talk mostly about blocking buffers
primary antibodies secondary or
anybody's and a detection system
so one of the most important things to
optimize reflexive Western blotting and
chemiluminescent Western blotting is the
blocking step in the blocking buffer you
want to use only high quality filtered
buffers particles and contaminants in
the washing and blocking buffers can
settle on the membrane and cause
fluorescent artifacts such as I showed
on the first slot and one of the earlier
slides you also want to use blocking
buffers or washing buffers that limit
the use of detergents which are often
quite off of common in these steps but
these detergents can cause fluorescent
background or autofluorescence in a
fluorescent based Western blotting also
the blocker you choose makes a big
impact on the results of your Western
blot and I'll talk about that on this
slide and on the next slide as you can
see up here on the top right we have a
western blot for three different targets
[Music]
displayed in green and red and you can
see a really good signal low background
with the chemical scientific present
blocker however if you use milk such as
on the right what you'll see is they
actually melt can sometimes over block
and we've made this entire second band
of green vanish in this case it's
knocked out detection of that band
also on how you image if the blot is wet
or dry it will have an impact on the
time and the signal intensity and this
is somewhat die dependent but it's also
blocking buffer dependence because it it
influences the oxidation of the dyes and
also how well the signal remains blocked
so if you look at the P 23 on the bottom
here there's a blot that's been imaged 2
days after the initial scan on the left
you can still see very bright red signal
across the gel where the milk signal
both in the green channel and the red
channel has beginning has started to
fade and we've lost that signal in that
fluorescent block
the blocker also has a lot of dependence
on nonspecific interactions you see and
on background which I display on this
slide using a variety of fairly ugly
Western blots
so once again on the left you have the
thermo scientific fluorescent blocker
and then five percent milk in the middle
and on the right another specialty
blocker and I just wanted to point out
some different highlights once again so
here we have EGFR stat3 and red 10 in
this case regardless of blocker very
strong blockers such as mouse milk the
thermal fluorescent blocker you can see
a lot of nonspecific binding in the EGFR
green channel so this is not the impact
of a bad blocker in this case blocking
is very good because you do not see
nonspecific bands in the red channel
from stat 3 or rass 10 so this is more
of an antibody problem something's
happened to this antibody it's either
degraded over time or you have some
nonspecific targets in this lysate due
to break down of the GEF marled molecule
probably a little bit of both all the
notches of binding is below the EGFR but
it's also most likely this EGFR antibody
was quite poor and old or degraded over
time
however once again in milk here's a
different target looking at rs10 you can
see the red signal from the wrath 10 is
almost completely blocked and
non-visible when using milk due to
excessive blocking
on the other end we have what can happen
with not a low level insufficient
blocking so in this case you see a high
level of red background across all of
the membrane and that's because there
was insufficient blocking to block both
the membrane fluorescence or it really
the case is blocking secondary and
primary antibody binding across the
target so you're getting a high
background due to insufficient blocking
but you can also see now if you look at
the rs10 signal the rs10 signal at the
bottom is actually quite high because
it's not over blocked in this case but
in this case is about finding the
optimal balance between blocking and
insufficient blocking for that target
so in terms of choosing the right
blocker buffer you do need to optimize
it's a little bit unpredictable of
different blocking buffers differ based
on the targets you're looking at we
recommend that you test multiple
multiple block and buffers to find the
best signal-to-noise ratio for your
targets but there are some
recommendations I would generally
recommend you start with our fluorescent
Western blot blocking buffer it's
designed to reduce cross reactivity and
produce high signal-to-noise ratios
another good choice is a starting block
it's sort of a middle-of-the-road
blocker that prevents both under
blocking and over blocking so it's a
good option to choose as a starting
point for blocking experiments
and then if you have very special cases
where you want to make sure your million
free you can try other obstinacy block
which uses fish serum that reduces
nonspecific binding to antibodies to
other to other mammalian proteins other
considerations if you're doing probing
for possible specific targets you may
want to avoid blockers containing
casings
because casein has a high number of
correlation sites on it and can
interfere with possible protein
detection
you
antibody selection of course is one of
the most important parts of Western
blotting and thermo scientific offers a
wide variety of both primary and
secondary antibodies we offer over
70,000 antibodies in fact it may be over
a hundred thousand antibodies at this
point in time so a very extensive
portfolio where we put a lot of effort
into validating our content so we want
to validate it for a specific
application you want to look for
antibodies that are specifically
validated for Western blotting because
antibodies at work in Eliza's or IHC or
immunofluorescence do not necessarily
work equivalently across different
applications and but another important
point to know is look for antibody
performance guarantee which allows you
to enable you to purchase antibodies of
confidence and try alternative
antibodies with minimal risk if they do
not work for your for your needs
it's similar to validation for primary
antibodies to be specific to the target
of interest you need to be careful about
the secondary antibody there's a variety
of considerations to look at you want to
use antibodies that of course are
matched to your your primary antibody so
species match you want to use good anti
goat or anti Mouse antibodies but you
also want to make sure they're highly
cross absorbed you want to look for
antibodies that have been cross
absorbers in bovine goat rabbit rats
human based on what their prime as their
target is to avoid these cross reactions
and allow you to do multiplex
experiments with minimal worry of
cross-contamination
but you also need to worry about what
dyes or enzymes are connected to the
secondary not all secondaries are
created equal
oops I'll come back to that I get to
slide in my brain so I'll hit the dyes
in a later slide but here his
experiments looking at how you set up
multiplex experiments and how you choose
what you want so here we have a rabbit
anti HSP primary hsp90 primary and then
mouse anti PDI anti PD three and we're
detecting with it anti rabbit Alexa four
plus 800 the green Channel and then anti
mouth Alexa four plus 680 for both of
those targets and you can get a very
clean Western blotting but here I'm only
using two species Mouse and and rabbit
which are very common if I want to do a
mule a higher flex experiment say a
four-plex experiment as you see over
here on the right how do I go about
doing that so you want to look for
multiple different species such here we
once again have the rabbit anti anti
hsp90 and the same Mouse but in this
case we've now used chicken a chicken
anti killer Trojan antibody and then up
top we are using an H a tag target so
this protein has been H a tagged and
then on we're detecting with an anti H a
an anti rabbit anti chicken and anti
mouse which allows a four-plex
experiment very clean minimal cross
reactivity and no background other
things you can look for are using
primary antibodies that are directly
conjugated so there's a variety of
commercially available directly
conjugated primary antibodies
particularly around anti tagged primary
antibodies but you also have the ability
to label primary antibodies through a
variety of labeling kits that are
available and so always consider that as
an option
particularly if you're going to be doing
the similar experiments over and over or
trying to do normalization so quite
often pre-labeled antibodies are
available to standard housekeeping gene
or tag tagged proteins
you
other things to worry about is what dyes
are connected to the secondary and how
what concentration you use them at
typically in a chemiluminescent Western
blotting one of the comment common
errors is to use too high of a
concentration and you get high
background because the chemiluminescence
signal and these substrates are very
very active and they do not need much
target to produce the light and turn
over the enzymatic reaction so it's not
uncommon to use one to twenty one to one
hundred or one to 200,000 Aleutians for
chemiluminescence detection with a
secondary antibody for fluorescence
since it's a direct measure and there's
no enzymatic reaction you actually want
to use a higher concentration of
secondary antibodies and I'll give you
some soy some data ask why over here on
the right so here I have a target that
is detected and with five different
fluorophores elects four plus forty
eight 555 647 excuse me six eighty and
800 and I used a secondary dilution of
one to five thousand one to ten thousand
or one to twenty thousand and here's the
antibody concentration of secondary at
down below so point four micrograms down
to point one microgram per mil as you
can see I got very good signal and a
good image regardless of what dye I
chose 48 down to eight hundred so all of
them are are equally available to you
and you should feel comfortable using
all of them don't feel that you should
be using just the 800 and 700 dyes and
what I love and use all these other dyes
quite frequently
but over on the right we look at
exposure time so as I increase the
dilution amount and I look at the the
488 channel you can see in this case it
only takes a few milliseconds to get the
image of 48 and then as I dilute it the
time increases to about 1.3 seconds
that's not much of a big deal in 48 488
channel is very very bright and very
bright dyes and then as I go to 555 you
can see it takes 0.7 seconds up to 1.6
seconds and then 6 15 goes from 1.5 to
2.8 seconds and if I go up to the 800
channel it may take up to 12 seconds up
to 27 seconds very little background in
the 800 channel so I can go for longer
periods of time but the dyes and the
lighting sources are quite often not as
powerful or is bright in the 700 and 800
channels and so the timing may take
longer depending on the imaging system
you're using and the lighting source and
camera that's detecting them
also different dyes have different
intensities much like chemiluminescence
where you can have low sensitivity ECL
substrates up to very very high
sensitivity substrates such as super
signal femto the secondary you use how
it's conjugated how much dye is on the
conjugate to little guy gives liek weak
signal too much dye can cause quenching
but also the brightness of dyes so here
on the left you see a Western blot done
with Alexa for plus secondary with Alexa
for plus 800 dye you get very good level
of sensitivity down to point zero 6
micrograms of lysate for both hsp90 and
h tab where if I use another 800 dye you
can see a significant lose sensitivity
even though it's the same species of
secondary and conjugated at a very
similar level that dye simply not as
bright and may be more prone to
oxidation than Alexa port plus
you
so when preparing you choosing your
floor for to do a multi to do a fourth
of western body really what you want to
consider is how many targets are you
trying to detect if you're only doing
one conjugate si saying any channel
would be appropriate you just you know
you have choices down to 500 you have
600 700 800 wavelength they're all
completely appropriate so you may just
start with Alexa Forrest + 650 if you're
going to do two targets you would want
to look for you know and you this could
be rat mouse goat it wouldn't matter at
all when you only looking at one target
if you're going to two targets you may
want to choose a rat rabbit and then a
mouse secondary and choose Alexa four
plus six fifty and then Alexa four five
four six as your second conjugate as you
go down and you want to do three targets
and you choose a rabbit 650 miles five
fifty and then if you can find a
different other species chicken or camel
or other species than you would choose
something like the 48 or the 800 die and
then with all four you could choose six
55 54 88 800 Alexa for 800 Alexa for 790
or look for directly labeled primaries
or direct secondaries to attack proteins
you
the last step in detection is imaging
and here I'll talk about imaging on the
eyebright imaging system but what I
talked about applies to a wide variety
of imaging system and there's just some
important features to look at and
consider with your imaging platform
so most imaging platforms are using CCD
based cameras some may use laser
scanners and photo diodes and put some
advantages and limitations of CCD
cameras they have a very nice dynamic
range compared to film dynamic they're
all generally 16-bit systems which will
give a dynamic range of about four point
eight
orders of magnitude imaging systems such
as I right have algorithms in them that
help determine the optimal exposure time
to not over expose or under expose your
sample which is a big issue with trying
to determine the right optimal exposure
times it's film
they allow direct image analysis
directly on the system or supporting
software they allow backup storage so
you don't have notebooks full of film
and they have direct quantitation built
right into them and you can instantly
visualize and share your results so
imaging systems are very very helpful
for that of course some limitations you
know you have instrument cost and
instrument maintenance compared to film
and when you're doing precip Western
blotting on CCD based systems compared
to chemiluminescence or you can sit
there and expose for a very long period
of time
with the rest of Western blotting
increased time does not necessarily mean
increased signal like it does with chemi
because you can get increased bleed
through from excitation light sources
which will just increase background as
you increase time
but imaging systems are very very
helpful and very useful and film is
dramatically reducing in usage in fact
I'd say well over 60% of customers are
you now using an imaging system you can
get very similar levels of sensitivity
as you can with film here you can see
different targets looking at a variety
of sensitivities both of the eyebright
imager and on film and here we're using
10 second exposures but the biggest
advantage of imaging systems is the
dynamic range in a determining optimal
exposure time imaging systems you can
simply select smart exposure it will
look for when the signal is saturating
and not allow it to go beyond saturation
and you can get very linear good signal
all the way down as you can see in the
the kuwaiti
image we're on film this you can see the
exposure is overdone the bands have bled
together and they're saturated even
though and get high levels of
sensitivity most of that data is not
useful you can see this on the graph
over on the right looking at dynamic
range on an imaging system compared to
film film has got a very narrow dynamic
range often less than 2 or a dice tours
of magnitude we're up top they saturate
quite quickly and you cannot tell that
it's saturated there's no data there to
tell you it's saturated very small
linear range and then at the bottom once
again you lose sensitivity or ability to
distinguish low differences between the
bands at the low end because many of the
pixels are still saturated even with a
very low signal where on the imaging
system you get very long dynamic range
and very linear dynamic range signal as
the signal increases and also the system
will tell you which bands are and pixels
are saturated that's up top so you'll be
able to determine if the
is useful for quantitation or not
you
also
the hybrid imaging system allows you to
select a wide variety of excitation and
emission channels to make a directly
compatible wide variety of dyes so you
have excitation channels from 450 to 485
515 - 556 10 to six thirty five six
fifty five to six eighty and then 750 to
six seven sixty five and then mission
channels from five five ten five sixty
five you know seven hundred seventy
seven thirty and eight hundred and this
makes them directly compatible wide
variety of dyes elect support plus the
die light 488 550 of Rio RTO dies and a
wide variety especially dyes where you
can combine excitation channels of 488
with emission at set 700 or 650 for a
variety of different die I'm having all
these channels available allows you do
four-plex imaging as you can see here a
very nice support Flex limited for
different target for different channels
and no bleed through or contamination
between channels and while this has
fixed five different excitation channels
we do recommend that you're using the
650 and 700 channel together as a small
amount of bleeds you can occur between
those channels
another advantage of an imaging system
is a very large field of view here I'm
imaging for different blots at the same
time I can imaging all the same time and
analyze them each independently as
different datasets and each channel is
it can be made as a separate image we're
doing that on film it is impossible
and we'll conclude sort of anthos last
slide showing an experiment beginning to
begin to end and some of the advantages
of fluorescent Western blind
so in this experiment we're looking at
the cleavage of PARP using star sporran
treatment and you can go with low levels
of stars pouring to increase the levels
of stores stores pouring treatment and
you'll get an increased amount of
cleavage occurring over time and then
we're also normalizing down here using a
gap DHS a loading control here's the two
independent channels so one I believe
taken into 800 channel and one in the
550 channel and you can get once again
the data and then the system will
automatically detect and give you
intensity values and you can normalize
it gets your load and control and you
can look at your non stimulated there's
no cleaved part when not stimulated and
then as you increase treatment you can
see increasing amount of apart
expression levels based on the treatment
level and you get very narrow error bars
very clean signal and can normalize it
and do this experiment in a matter of
seconds on the instrument
and with that I like to finish and say
Western blotting is a beginning to end
process you need to look at what you're
doing all the way from the separation
steps and optimize your buffers and gel
chemistry's and ladders to your transfer
devices your membranes used and how your
transfer based on the molecular weight
of your target and then detect look at
optimizing your buffers your reagents
your antibodies and then your imaging
systems and like that I'd like to stop
and answer any questions and thank you
for your time
questions and thank you for your time
Thank You dr. Haney for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for the first question is what is
more sensitive chemiluminescence
chemiluminescent or fluorescent western
blotting and by how much
oh yeah that's a very common question
and it's really going to depend on the
substrate you're using some substrates
the basic ECL substrates have fairly
limited sensitivity will have
sensitivity very similar to fluorescent
will be approximately equivalent where
if you use a very high sensitivity
sensitive substrate like femto or dura
chemiluminescence ative I mean down to
the femto gram level it's also dependent
on the time you quarter the image
fluorescent images are typically very
very short you're taking a fluorescent
image and somewhere between less than a
second to 20 or 30 seconds and then
you're really capped at that period of
time for us that images really don't
have a benefit of taking an image for a
longer period of time you just get the
same signal or get background due to
excitation light we're a chemi image
since it's producing its own light and
there's no other background you can
leave that the system sit on the can be
signal for a very long time or or let it
sit on film and so that way of chemical
method can be more sensitive probably by
about one one make one order of
magnitude maybe about tenfold from slow
picogram level to mid-tempo gram level
depending on the target and your primary
antibodies efficiency
thank you for that answer the next
question is I sometimes the uneven
backgrounds in both chemiluminescent or
florescent detection what are some other
factors that account for this so in
additional to the blocking and handling
that I talked about definitely a good
blocker strong enough blocker and
handling other things that impact
background can quite often come down to
very simple things and how you're
handling and processing it when you're
shaking a Western block in a tray or a
processor and rocking back and forth if
you have uneven liquid covering and it
can cause uneven backgrounds shakers can
be will cause less liquid to be in the
center or more at the edges which will
give you uneven background and/or
swirling and that can cause an impact
also cutting membranes with rusty
scissors and chemiluminescence Western
blots will cause a signal and on even
background in the course fingerprints
and other touching of the membrane but
be just be very careful that you using
enough liquids over your membranes and
blots and you're allowing enough time of
the wash step you know and changing your
wash but you wash buffers frequently
after blocking and secondary antibody
also if you're doing a chemiluminescent
western blot quite often people leave
too much substrate on the membrane so
it's quite wet and they'll be puddling
of the substrate around the block and
that can cause edge effects on the blot
or very hot spots at the edges of the of
the membrane those are sort of the main
things that can cause it all so make
sure when you're transferring the gel
cut off the stacker and other things so
you don't get a low density acrylamide
embedded in your membrane when you
transfer that can also cause background
issues
I would like to once again thank dr.
Paul Haney for his presentation I would
also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everybody know that
today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through September of
2019 please share with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again soon goodbye